if you watch The Big Bang Theory on CBS
television you see these clueless nerds
who are doormats when it comes to the
opposite sex right and you realize is
there any basis in a reality
first of all none of my friends are like
that and all my friends are physicists
right well there is a kernel of truth
and that is some of these individuals
may suffer from something called
Asperger's syndrome which is a mild form
of autism these people are clueless when
it comes to social interactions they
don't look you in the eye for example
and yet they have fantastic mental and
mathematical capabilities we think for
example that Isaac Newton had Asperger's
the greatest scientist of all time was
very strange he had no friends to speak
of he could not carry a decent
conversation and yet here he was
spitting out some of the greatest
theories in the history of science
calculus the universal law of
gravitation the theory of optics and we
think he had Asperger's syndrome
now Asperger's syndrome is a mild form
of autism and in autism we have what I
call savants that is people that have an
IQ of maybe 80 but have incredible
mathematical and musical abilities in
fact some of these individuals can hear
one Symphony and just play it by memory
on a piano other people could be in a
helicopter have a helicopter ride over
Manhattan see the entire New York Harbor
and then from memory sketched the entire
harbor in fact if you want to see it go
to JFK Airport in New York City and you
will see it as you enter the
international terminal so what is it
about these people well first of all a
lot of them had injuries to the left
temporal lobe one individual had a
bullet as a child go right through the
left temporal lobe another person vibed
in a swimming pool and injured very
badly the left temporal lobe and these
people walked up with incredible
mathematical abilities as a consequence
and so what is it about their brains
well Einstein
brain has actually been preserved
Einstein when he died had a autopsy in
which case the pathologist stole the
brain without permission of the family
he just realized that he was sitting
next to something historic took the
brain took it home with him
and it was sitting in a jar in his home
for decades he even drove across the
country with the jar inside his trunk
and there's even a TV special where you
can actually see the cut-up brain of
Albert Einstein and you realize first of
all the brain is a little bit different
you can't tell by looking at it that is
so remarkably different but you realize
that the connections between the
prefrontal cortex and the parietal lobe
a connection that is accentuated in
people that do abstract reasoning is
thickened so there definitely is a
difference in the brain of Einstein but
the question is did it make iron Stein
or did Einstein make this change of the
brain are champions born or are they
made that still does not know because
people who exercise mental abilities
mathematical abilities they can thicken
that product that part of the brain
themselves so we know that people who do
well in mathematics brain scans clearly
show that their brains are slightly
different from the average brain so in
conclusion we're still children with
regards to understanding how this
process takes place tonight
don't go home and bang yourself on the
left temporal lobe we don't know how it
works we just know that in a tiny
fraction of these cases people with
injury to the left temporal lobe some of
them become super geniuses
you